what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the death of the Venom
verse we're covering the first three
issues in this video and this initially
opens up in an alternate reality
basically with what would normally be
the original origin of carnage which is
to say at some point in time Eddie Brock
and Cletus Cassidy were both in a jail
cell and the Venom symbiote broke Eddie
Brock out of jail and then in turn left
a little bit of itself behind which
basically became the Carnage symbiote
and then bonded itself to Cletus the
difference here is that the Carnage
symbiote emerges and then kills Eddie
Brock and then leaves Cletus behind so
what's going on here so for those of you
guys who have not been following Carnage
up to this point one thing to know is
that the Carnage symbiote does not have
a host at the moment that in the main
Marvel Universe it is normally bonded to
Cletus Cassidy but it's kind of out
there doing its own thing not only that
it's been consolidating a massive amount
of power so what it's doing now is
literally hopping through the Multiverse
and killing every version of Venom that
it can possibly find and so what this
does is this transitions to another
reality and we pick up with Anne
weighing from Earth 1051. now for those
of you guys who aren't familiar with
that Earth 1051 was a universe where
basically Eddie Brock's son Dylan and
there's a whole history behind this
which you can find the link to that
playlist at the end of this video that
Dylan Brock's son had effectively become
like this Uber symbiote and basically
killed all the superheroes on Earth and
then replaced them with symbiote
duplicates and comes from that reality
if she was one of the very last few
humans that was left alive that was
actually trying to work against Dylan in
that Universe ultimately he was defeated
and so what you have now is What's
called the Venom core if you want to
refer to it that way but essentially
they're on the hunt for Cletus across
the Multiverse so we're kind of picking
up in the middle of his murderous
Rampage across all of existence with
regards to these different Venoms and as
they're making their way through here
what we get is a kind of flashback
battle where you had Carnage facing off
against this reality's version of Laura
Kinney x-23 who had the Venom Symbian
and Carnage was able to take her out
with a quickness not only that there was
also an instance where Ant-Man in this
universe had also had the Venom symbiote
or potentially in an alternate reality
had the Venom Sybian and when that
happened of course the fight broke out
between himself and Carnage and Carnage
had killed Ant-Man and then went forward
from there so the question is why why
what's the motivation behind killing
these different versions of Venom well
one of the things that we've learned in
recent years in Marvel Comics is that
anytime anyone becomes a host for a
symbiote the Symbiote will leave behind
what's referred to as a codex kind of
like a genetic version of spray painting
Venom was here on that person's DNA but
the Codex is kind of like a source of
its power so when Carnage kills these
people who are hosts for the Venom
symbiote what he's doing in taking their
codex is he's expanding his own powers
he's growing his own abilities but he's
actually on the hunt for a few
particular things and we'll find out
what those are over the course of this
story now one of the things that we do
is we actually pick up with a character
named virus we will find out who he is
but at the start of this it's not who
you think it is and the reason I say
that is because the virus armor has
appeared in Marvel Comics before in
years past it belonged to Matt gargan
also known as the Scorpion but he's long
since lost it right there's actually
somebody else in the suit of armor one
of the reasons why you see like all the
Band-Aids and tape and stuff like that
is because the armor was basically
destroyed and now it's kind of been
recreated again but the forces of Anne
and her group are just like traveling
from one place to the next now this
takes us to a reality where Carnage
comes across Mania now Mania is a really
really cool character in Marvel in more
recent years she's a character named
scream who's also kind of like an
anti-venom character we'll talk about
what that means later on in the video
but in this reality she still simply
just Mania which is to say she's based
more off the Venom symbiote than the
Carnage Symbian now under any normal
circumstance this would not really be a
significant thing but as you guys will
notice there's this kind of Mark on the
chest of mania there's a reason she has
that and in fact it's actually going to
amplify Carnage's powers to a huge level
as time goes on and so what ends up
happening is that in the fight between
Carnage and Mania of course the forces
of and weighing show up and they do what
they can where they can but the reality
is that this is not simply just the
Carnage symbiote that we traditionally
know from the main Marvel Universe he's
way more powerful than he used to be and
so what they do is they kind of grab
Andy Benton right they grab Mania in
this alternate universe and then kind of
lure Carnage into a little bit of a trap
and when he gets to that location and
brings in the rest of her forces right
agent Spider-Man from Earth 1051 agent
Deadpool from 1051 and agent Hawkeye
from 1051. one of the things to realize
is there's no human element to these
guys they're all 100 symbiote right like
the human part is gone but the funny
thing here is that it's Child's Play for
Carnage to take these guys eyes out
that's just how powerful he is now he
takes these dudes out with the greatest
of ease but Mania ever The Reckless
character jumps in goes to fight Carnage
and is immediately killed and what that
does when he basically takes her codex
he also absorbs the artifact on her
chest which is a hellmark now the reason
why this matters is because in Marvel
Comics a hellmark is basically a mark
given to a person that could potentially
become a hell Lord at some point in the
future but it's most commonly bestowed
on people by Mephisto now does this mean
that you know essentially Carnage is now
Ghost Rider no but what it does mean is
that one of the three traditional
weaknesses that symbiotes have he's now
immune to the power of fire that he can
no longer be harmed by fire in any form
not only that because he has the
hellmark he can actually summon demons
which is pretty crazy right because
basically Carnage has become a hell Lord
now it's kind of nuts and so the only
thing they can really do is just like
get out of there as fast as they can
because now being able to channel the
power of fire he's way more of a match
for any of these symbiotes than he ever
was before and so that's when we get to
the second thing that Carnage is trying
to attain which is the ability to
manipulate electricity and this comes by
way of a reality that he ends up in
where you have what's known as the
Symbiote six in effect the Sinister Six
all of whom have been minimized right Dr
Octopus Craven the Hunter and Rhino and
of course Electro and so initially the
fight here is actually kind of
interesting in the sense that they keep
Carnage on the ropes just because
there's like six of them and one of
Carnage so even despite all the
abilities that he has facing off against
traditional villains is no small thing
because villains don't hold back the
same way that Heroes do and so because
of this it makes them incredibly deadly
to someone like Carnage but the funny
thing is that because of the power of
the hellmark he summons his own own
demonic forces that are able to go
against the Symbiote six and that's when
Anne's forces jump in because in
monitoring this entire conflict they
come to the realization this is one of
the best chances they would have right
that it'd be very easy and all the
distraction and all the chaos that
Carnage wouldn't necessarily be paying
attention and it would be relatively
easy to take him out in fact the exact
opposite happens that in all of this
chaos in pandemonium they underestimate
what Carnage is capable of and that by
using the full totality of his
symbiote's powers at this point in time
tendrils go in every direction and
virtually everybody is ripped to pieces
the only way that the forces of Anne
weighing are able to make it out in the
face of pretty much all the members of
the symbiote6 that are destroyed is that
one of them is able to use Sonics and
that when that happens it forces him to
retreat but not before he was able to
take the Codex of Electro which means
now the carnid Symbiote is immune to
electricity and he's immune to fire now
the question has to be yes why in the
world is he tracking down all these
different abilities right these
immunities well one we know that this is
leading to like a massive fight between
what is essentially the main Marvel
Universe version of Eddie Brock who's
kind of like the antithesis of the
beyonders he's this ridiculously
powerful character and like Carnage
itself but we're actually going to see
The Return of a very familiar face in
Marvel Comics which is a showdown for
the ages given like the level of power
that Carnage has know the Symbiote God
is coming back and it's gonna be dope
it's gonna be so amazing right some are
the Symbiotes man it's gonna be it's
just it's really really cool and so
following this of course with him
jumping into this new reality he ends up
coming across a fight between shriek and
a guy named chaos engine now chaos
engine is the one that actually has the
Venom symbiote shriek herself is similar
to the main Marvel Universe version but
the reality here is that the Carnage
that she recognizes here is not the
Carnage that she knows but she doesn't
recognize the difference that when you
have Carnage who shows up here and
weighing enter forces show up here yet
again now this is not designed to be
like some kind of time skip or anything
like that one of the things that's
happening is that as soon as carness
jumps to a different reality they
immediately chase after him because the
big concern here is that every single
time Carnage kills a Venom symbiote
whose Powers he can absorb he becomes
more powerful for the other symbiotes
that don't really have a level of power
that he's particularly chasing after
that in reality it's just him kind of
honing his fighting abilities but with
every Venom he kills he becomes stronger
so they're constantly chasing after this
guy there is no reprieve there's no
momentary break it's no like okay well
after this fight with Carnage let's all
go get dinner at The Sizzler that's not
what's Happening Here
and it's kind of cool to see because
even with the forces of Anne and the
fact that Rhino from The symbiote6 has
now joined Anne's forces if only to gain
revenge over his teammates that were
killed by Carnage the main goal of
Carnage here is to go after chaos engine
why because he has the ability to
manipulate Sonics and that in doing so
if he's able to overcome this guy kill
him and take his codex and his powers
then Carnage will be completely immune
to any and all forms of energy out there
outside of ultra high level reality
warping that could destroy him he'd be
immune to fire electricity and Sonic
right the three main weaknesses of any
particular Symbian such as it is and
forces realize that if chaos engine does
have the ability to manipulate Sonics
protecting him at all costs is the most
important thing and that ultimately they
open a portal and they essentially jump
away and so because of this Anne starts
to realize that having Venom symbiotes
on their side is okay right it is a
pretty nifty thing to have but in
reality Carnage is just way more
powerful than they are so what she needs
is somebody out there that has the
ability to destroy Venom symbiotes what
she ends up doing is traveling to the
main Marvel Universe and going to find
Scream the main Marvel Universe version
of Andy Benton also known as anti-venom
because for those of you guys who are
not familiar with anti-venom in Marvel
Comics it's literally the antithesis of
Venom that anti-venom has the ability to
destroy any and all traces of the Venom
symbiote within any one particular
person not only that anti-venom has the
ability to like cure people of illnesses
for example like in the main Marvel
Comics anti-venom almost siphoned Peter
Parker's radioactive blood out of his
body right like cleaned him of his
spider powers that if it had been
successful he would have lost his
ability to be Spider-Man it was a pretty
nut story right it was awesome I'm
really glad we covered it right it was a
really really crazy story there but
following that right they kind of give
Andy Benton the whole rundown of
everything that's been happening up to
this point right like Carnage is
traveling through the most universities
trying to kill every Venom he can come
across so he can destroy some Uber
villain out there or Uber character out
there they don't really know what his
main motivation is that he's basically
gained a whole host of powers and that
he is immune to most traditional
weaknesses of Symbiotes and that
anti-venom is really the only one that
they see as being able to help them
because she has the ability to shut down
the powers of any particular symbiote
that's out there what's so crazy is they
end up tracking Carnage to an alternate
universe where the war of Realms led to
the wholesale conquering of Earth now
the war of Realms was a story that was
done relatively recently in Marvel which
basically saw like the different Realms
that exist out there in Thor Mythos
right yotenheim and spartalheim and all
that kind of stuff that it was just like
a giant War among all those groups it
was led by a guy named malakith and that
he almost destroyed the entirety of
Earth he was ultimately stopped right
and the war of Realms Was Won by midgard
and the good guys and so on and so forth
in this universe it was a whole
different kettle of beans right like the
war of Realms came to Earth and at the
end of the day Humanity survived but
Asgard now resides on Earth itself and
it's like the de facto governing body
now of course they're met by Valkyrie
which is not Jane Foster the valkyrie as
she exists right now it's actually the
daughter of bruneheld the original
Valkyrie in Marvel Comics when I say
original I mean like original right like
the one who was on The Defenders way
back in like the 70s and 80s in Marvel
Comics like OG OG Valkyrie and Marvel
brunhild was cool right she was one of
those super underrated characters but of
course as you would expect in the middle
of all this Carnage shows up
and Garner starts attacking everybody
and that chaos engine is one of like the
few people who can hold him at Bay by
firing off Sonic energy but lest we
forget yes Carnage is vulnerable to
Sonics but Carnage always learns after
every conflict he's engaged in which
means he knows how to Bob and weave and
Dodge the powers of chaos engine right
he's not immune to it but he does know
how to get around it and so that's kind
of the funny thing because what ends up
happening here is that Andy Benton right
scream ends up manifesting and bringing
in other versions of Anti-Venom and they
initially go after Carnage and for a
moment it looks like she's gonna get the
upper hand because all she has to do is
touch it that's the only thing she has
to do what she doesn't realize here is
that he does not have a host so there's
nobody to suck any of this stuff off of
right like there's no one to quote
unquote cure that we don't know exactly
what would happen if scream got her
hands on a symbiote with no host and try
try to cure it right try to basically
disincorporate it or eliminate it would
she successfully be able to destroy
Carnage and so in the midst of all of
this and because all these Venom
symbiotes are weak to fire he conjures
the hellmark manifests a boatload of
Hellfire in order to keep them at Bay
and then uses it as a distraction to
start taking out these different
characters then he targets virus and
what we end up finding out here is that
virus is actually Dylan Brock from the
earth 1051 Universe the guy that
basically became a villain and then took
over the entirety of Earth only to
change his ways and go back to being a
good guy he's a little kid inside the
suit of armor and everybody's kind of
shocked and surprised at the fact that
like Andy would bring him to this
conflict in the first place but in
reality here like she really cares more
about the life of Dylan her biological
son than anybody else so she like
immediately goes to rescue her son and
then of course treating it as a kind of
distraction anti-venom in everybody ends
up stepping in they do momentarily get
the upper hand on Carnage but then he
just absorbs them all into himself
everybody except for screen right
everybody except for Andy Benton the
kicker about all this like I said is we
don't know what would happen if a
Carnage symbiote with no host absorbed
an Anti-Venom and so literally these
guys are bursting out of him but this is
only three issues in so I have to
believe this was actually one of the
worst choices they could have made by
allowing him to absorb anti-venom
because now it means he can literally
just touch a Venom Symbian strip them of
their abilities take their codex and
walk away it actually makes it
infinitely easier for him to do what
he's been doing so far so to answer a
question some of you guys had yes this
is the main Marvel Universe version of
the Carnage symbiote no it does not take
place in the main Marvel Universe the
Carnage symbiote is out in the
Multiverse killing every version of
Venom it can possibly find right so just
kind of clear that up a little bit so so
what this does is this opens up at the
tail end of the last video that we
covered and as always if you need to get
caught up at the end of this video we'll
have a playlist for you guys to click on
so you can get caught up with death of
venomverse but basically the forces that
are out there right the anti-carnage
forces basically brought in Anti-Venom
and historically speaking anti-venom has
been a symbiote that can actually kill
off and eradicate other symbiotes a
perfect example of this was when it
almost took away the radioactive
material in Peter Parker's blood and it
basically would have turned him into a
regular guy and he wouldn't have been
Spider-Man anymore The Hope in doing
this is that it would have effectively
neutralized the current symbiote by
pouring an exceedingly strong acid on a
relatively weak material it would have
just dissolved it such as it is what it
ended up doing is it actually allowed
all the different versions of Venom that
Carnage has ever killed and consumed to
basically Escape it allowed them to kind
of rise up against him the difference
here is that instead of coming back as
their normal form the anti-venom
properties merged with them basically
turning them into anti-carnage symbiotes
which is amazing and I'm kind of amazed
that we never really had anything like
that before right like anti-carnate
symbiotes just so you guys who are new
to Comics just so you know this is how
new Concepts pop up because what's going
to happen mark my words at some future
point in time another writer is going to
draw on this in the main Marvel Universe
with regards to Carnage and you're going
to start seeing an anti-carnate symbiote
that exists out there right toxin You
could argue that to a degree but not
really right I mean he's kind of a
merger of both but a true anti-carnate
symbiote that will appear in the future
but this goes exactly the way that you
would expect it to that with these
anti-carnate symbiotes they're largely
at least seem to be immune to the forces
or at least to the abilities of the
current symbiote itself there really
doesn't seem to be a whole lot he can do
to basically absorb them conquer them so
on and so forth we're actually going to
see that's not the case here in a little
while but the cool thing is that now
they see it as their opportunity now
they see it as their chance to basically
take Carnage down once and for all now
one of the things that we get to see
here which is really really cool is a
dream Stone Venom now for those of you
guys who don't know what that means in
Marvel Comics in the war of Realms
crossover event which was effectively
like a massive Asgardian conflict that
ultimately came to Earth there was a
point where a dream Stone was presented
to Eddie Brock and the idea behind the
dreamstone is that it can grant the
various desires of whoever it is that
wields it in the case of Eddie Brock it
was a Venom Samia that could manifest
all kinds of weapons that were outside
the traditional scope of what a Venom
symbiote was capable of it was an
artificial way to enhance his abilities
and it lasted for a relatively short
period of time and then we went into the
current Venom run where he became the
king in Black after defeating Noel and
all that kind of crazy stuff which was
cool but thing about this is that this
version of Venom can basically craft all
kinds of physical arms and Armament
which is how it is that he's able to
take the Symbiote and almost kind of
convert his physical structure into that
of almost like a god-like type Warrior
being with like a massive Scythe right
the Venom symbiote can't normally do
that but in effect it allows him to do
what a Carnage symbiote can do which is
pretty awesome and it's pretty cool to
see now everybody else just kind of
takes their shots where they can when
they can and Truth to tell they get a
little carried away with themselves
right they get a little carried away
with like dragging the conflict on
everybody trying to get their own licks
in as opposed to just trying to take him
out as fast as humanly possible and
that's why you see like Anne weighing
who's kind of the leader of this anti uh
Carnage Force that's just kind of like
you know don't give him a chance to get
his footing he's weakened but he's still
dangerous that kind of a thing the
reality is if they were doing what they
were supposed to do they would have
annihilated him right off the bat
because one of the things that Anne
realized when these different consumed
Venoms had escaped from Carnage is that
he was now back to his normal weakness
right the same weaknesses that all
symbiotes have fire Sonics electricity
that kind of thing so it would be
relatively easy to destroy the sky but
they let it drag on a little bit too
long and that's exactly how this plays
out right that you basically have dream
Stone Venom who goes in for the killing
blow and then he ends up being impaled
by Carnage right and Carnage like kills
him on the spot so what this does is it
basically turn faces everything that
we've seen so far that where Carnage
himself even believed that these guys
were Beyond his ability to absorb that
with the death of dreamstone Venom this
shows that Carnage can start killing all
of them right he can start going after
all of them just like he hoped he could
and that's when he kind of goes back on
the offense again that's kind of the
cool thing right the Carnage literally
had a kind of crisis of confidence in
the moment when he lost the people that
he had absorbed because he thought he
was back to being his normally weak self
it's awesome to see that's not the case
now the dreamstone Symbiote actually
bonds itself to a different version of
Eddie Brock who got the Venom symbiote
and became Spider-Man and in turn you
almost have a kind of double symbiote
bonded to a person right Venom times two
and when this guy manifests right he
says Like You Had Your Shot Carnage you
got close but you blew it and we think
you know that we are Venom right so
literally this is not Eddie Brock from
the main Marvel universe is what I want
to establish here that version of Eddie
Brock is off doing the whole King in
Black fighting Meridius threat achieving
god-like levels of power that's not
what's going on here this is just an
alternate version of Eddie that just
happens to have two symbiotes bondage
whom now instead of one but this is a
really cool moment here because what it
does is it shows how powerful Carnage is
now this is a massive boost because one
thing to know Carnage has not reabsorbed
any other symbiotes so this is just the
current symbiote by itself over the
years in Marvel Comics ever since the
original introduction of Carnage going
into like the the original Maximum
Carnage event we always knew there
seemed to be this kind of power
discrepancy between the Venom symbiote
the Carnage symbiote and Spider-Man
there was just something about him that
seemed to make him more powerful and
Marvel's hinted at it over the years
right it's stronger and faster than
Venom that kind of thing but what really
seemed to set Carnage over the top was
the fact that there were no real mental
blocks in place there was no morality
Clause here right Venom over the years
is kind of waxed and waned and changed
and things like that and even when Venom
and Spider-Man first teamed up when
Carnage first appeared it was like okay
look we got to put our animosity towards
each other to the side and we have to
like face off against this this joint
enemy right the enemy of my enemy is my
friend with carnages not that way right
either he's going to kill you or he's
not and there really is no in between so
that just kind of recklessness and that
lack of concern for anybody's life or
the the value of life in any capacity
seemed to kind of put him over the edge
what this establishes here is assuming
all things are equal which is to say the
the capabilities and the strength of one
Venom symbiote in a universe is
comparable if not exact to another Venom
symbiote in Another Universe assuming
that's all the same Carnage is Way
Beyond the normal abilities of Venom in
any one particular Universe right which
really kind of shows how it was he was
able to so easily overcome these
different Venoms that existed in these
different alternate realities because
that was the question a lot of you guys
had a lot of you guys were kind of like
how is how is Carnage able to just so
easily kill Venoms they should be able
to put up a pretty considerable fight
and it shouldn't be like a cat and mouse
game this kind of establishes why that's
the case but even then with his back
against the wall to a degree he starts
reaching out and grabbing each and every
one of these different symbiotes that he
had previously absorbed and reabsorbs
them back into himself that takes his
power back to where it was before but
now he's even more powerful than he was
before and the reason for that is
because the first thing he does is he
takes out anti-venom right kills this
guy right on the spot so now he doesn't
have to worry about them using their
abilities to like force these different
venom symbiots out of his body or
anything along those lines and the other
forces right the Venom forces start to
realize this window's closing incredibly
fast but honestly it's closing faster
than they think it is because there
really is no conceivable way for these
guys to defeat him now right there's
just not going to happen so all that
ends up happening here is he goes after
the Venom symbiote that has the dream
Stone takes this guy out and absorbs it
and then in turn he goes forward once
everybody just kind of teleports away
because the best they can do is just
Flee for their lives remarshall their
forces and try to come back and take
another shot at him at some point in
time this transitions over to another
universe and what you have here is a
Silver Surfer who be became Venom the
kicker to all of this and what's so cool
about this is that this guy is about to
be met with the power of the Enigma
Force and that's where things go
sideways really for pretty much
everybody in the Multiverse the reason
for that and for those of you guys who
don't know in Marvel Comics you have
What's called the microverse in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is called the
quantum realm but the microverse is
literally a microscopic Universe from
that microscopic Universe comes the
Enigma Force Marvel calls it the Enigma
Force because they just never bothered
to explain what it was that it could
really do it's the power of light and
like that's it right it's just it's
literally a plot device right like it
does whatever the user needs it to do in
order to like win right Spider-Man
punches The Incredible Hulk into the
atmosphere during acts of Vengeance for
example so the thing about this
that by absorbing right killing this
Silver Surfer symbiote and absorbing the
Enigma Force into itself Carnage now
becomes the total antithesis of null the
Symbiote God why because that was
established in the king and black
storyline if you guys remember that and
this is a great callback if you guys
remember that story that the Enigma
Force was kind of like the light to the
darkness that null represented when
Eddie Brock attained the Enigma Force in
the original King and black event that's
how it was he was able to defeat null
that's exactly what happens with Carnage
here but the question has to be asked
what happens when a bad guy gets this
well you transition to a full contingent
of the Avengers the X-Men like even CLIA
who's Doctor Strange in this universe
all of whom are channeling their powers
together to try to defeat null the
Symbiote God in this universe none of it
works but what ends up happening here is
Carnage now with the power of the Enigma
Force and the hellmark which basically
allows him to tap into the abilities of
summoning demons and so on immediately
makes a B-Line for this universe's
version of null the Symbiote God and the
fight is amazing because the Avengers of
this universe have no clue what's going
on now this is one of the things that I
do want to establish here because they
look up in the sky and they're like is
that Carnage right taking the fight to
null and it's like I mean it looks like
it what's the call here right and
Magneto just kind of looks for a second
it's like the enemy of my enemy is my
friend right so they basically form a
kind of alliance with Carnage now what I
say they form an alliance I mean they
decide to fight alongside Carnage we'll
see what Carnage's reaction to that
Alliance is here in a second but the
fight between him and null is intense
now when it comes to know the Symbiote
God one of the things that we didn't
know is how null function right is null
multiversal is null Universal as a
concept null is multiversal but every
Universe has its own version of null
that's what this establishes so this
fight between these guys is just crazy
because initially Noel doesn't know how
to respond to this right like the whole
statement here is you are not from this
realm a cast off from another reality
come here to face Oblivion and the
response of Carnage is yes Oblivion is
what I deserve if I cannot destroy you
no then what chance do I have against
the king in black and the response of
null is do you not know me I am the king
in Black now what Noel doesn't realize
is that in the main Marvel Universe his
reality's counterpart right like that
version of himself in that Universe was
destroyed by Eddie Brock and Eddie
became the new King in Black of that
Universe he didn't know that he has no
idea what's going on in other realities
all he knows is what's going on in his
universe and so that's why Carnage says
not on my world not on the world that
matters now of course this is also
hinting and really establishing what
we've already known which is Carnage is
doing all of this in the first place but
because he's aware of how powerful Eddie
Brock is now he's aware that Eddie Brock
in the main Marvel universe is the king
in Black his level of power is Way
Beyond that of Carnage and the only way
for Khan is to finally kill Eddie Brock
as the king in black and take his place
as the king in black is to harness
enough power to be able to topple him
right to basically gain the power of
null the Symbiote God combined with all
these other things that we've seen the
hellmark and so on and so forth and
that's what's so wild because at that
point basically The Avengers jump in
right Thor's like strike my friends
while we can right this is the moment in
which we turn the tide and Magneto even
uses his power over magnetism to seize
control of null cyclops's optic beams
are basically Modified by Doctor Strange
so instead of just pulling energy from
some other dimension because cyclops's
eyes are a portal to a different
dimension that he actually ends up
pulling energy from the dark dimension
which basically amplifies and Ace's
Powers even more capable than they have
been which is something that I really
want to see in the future right but none
of it works against no because at that
point Captain America turns to Carnage
and he's like on your feet Soldier
thanks to you we've got null on the
defensive we need you we can take him
down Avengers Assemble but before he can
say a symbol Carnage kills him
Carnage kills Captain America right and
then knows like these are all
distractions so in fact when they
thought it was a team up between the
Avengers in Carnage it's actually a team
up between Carnage and Noel who killed
The Avengers together
it's amazing I absolutely love it
because in response we get like the most
null statement ever right where he's
like I have come to destroy this world
to murder it and no one will stand in my
way no one right and then we find out
that much like the original King and
black event this version of null has
seized control of the celestials in this
universe and the funny thing here is
Carnage doesn't care right he literally
says if it makes you feel better I'll
finish what you started I'll end this
world for you after you're dead and when
one of the celestials tries to go after
him he kills it on the spot so literally
the power of Carnage is just at this
astronomical level now right a god that
is what I've become that is what I
always was now the forces of Anne
weighing do show up here where they
teleport in like at this moment when
Carnage is just fighting no half a
second too late because had they shown
up when like The Avengers were alive
they probably could have mounted an
effective resistance against both
Carnage and null such as it is these
guys are idiots so they always show up
late so the thing here is that when they
arrive they're kind of like okay what do
we do like how do we find a way to
defeat Carnage and they're like well I
mean we have to find a way to keep
ourselves alive and for a while they
basically fight dragons right these guys
are useless as tits and a Warhawk they
don't really serve a purpose at all
right so like literally Carnage fighting
no which is like the real main brunt of
all of this this it's it's one of the
best fights I've ever seen because null
in turn when like the forces of Anne try
to like hold him and capture him right
keep them in place that kind of thing
because the idea is to grab null and
basically teleport him away it's a smart
idea but a dumb idea at the same time
it's a smart idea in the moment because
they basically would prevent Carnage
from attaining the power of a king in
black and then everything would just
come crumbling down around them right
then he would be guaranteed to be
unstoppable so if they teleport null
potentially to some other reality that's
basically empty right like just a dead
world where like there's no heroes or
anything then like sure right then I
guess the Multiverse would be saved for
the time being but it's also kind of a
dumb decision because all Carnage has to
do is just jump to a different Universe
where null hasn't been destroyed kill
that version of null and then we're
right back to square run again right so
it's only ever really a stop Gap measure
such as it is it doesn't work because
again the forces of and suck and like
know the symbiid god escapes and then
just starts killing them all but only
like this is this is this is so amazing
because in their attempts to capture
null they leave Carnage wide open this
guy stats null through the chest right
and he's like oh I'll know your power
I'll know it all and I'll put it to much
better use than you ever would and
that's when they realized it's game over
done right because this guy immediately
absorbs Knowles power and I gotta say
man Carnage as a king in Black like just
look at him man it looks like it looks
so amazing but like this guy is now
Unstoppable there's no conceivable way
they can win and even and son Dylan
right who like has this kind of powered
suit of armor and that's how they
teleport around where Anne's like we
have to get out of here his response is
no no no it's like you said before we
just need more forces right we just need
more guys so they open up a portal bring
in more guys it's Lambs to the slaughter
right I mean it's a kill box right
literally it's just Carnage ripping
through them all and there's nothing
they can do and Anne's like we have to
get out of here like stop teleporting
people in and Dylan's like no it's just
like you said right it's just like you
planned and she's she's like no we have
to leave there's no surviving this
there's no way we get out of this alive
but that's when Carnage starts to Target
Dylan because it's like if I can destroy
the guy who can teleport forces in but
can also teleport forces out then it's
game over for everybody here he kills
Dylan on the spot right just bow impales
this guy there's no way in or out and so
at that point when they try to seize him
he's just like nope done and just like
kills everybody here except for Anne
everybody's dead right like Anne Wang is
the only person left alive we don't
really even know why he spared her and
there's even this kind of allusion to
the idea that maybe Dylan is not fully
dead right maybe Dylan may come back in
some capacity because lest we forget
right this version of Dylan the daughter
of Anne from their Universe this guy is
the one that basically became the king
in Black of his own Universe right like
he's the one that killed off all the
superheroes in that universe and
replaced them all with symbiotes so it's
entirely possible that this kid may come
back but as it stands now man it's game
over sun sun sun done so so the question
has to be asked what happens when this
version of Carnage confronts the main
Marvel Universe Eddie Brock with all the
power that he has well we'll find out
whenever that story kicks off with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end if you need to get caught up
on death of Venom verse make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later
peace